صور من ريف ادلب اذن بعد وقوع الزلزال
نتابعها معكم
صور من ريف ادلب نعم للصور الاوليه بعد
وقوع الزلزال طبعا الناس هرعت الى الشوارع
واستذكر طبعا لحظات الرعب
قبل اسبوعين في زلزال السادس من فبراير
الزلزال المدمر الذي كان مركزه كرمان مرعش
في تركيا اما زلزال اليوم فهو قريب اكثر
الى المناطق السوريه هو في
ولايه هاتاي التي كانت تعرف سابقا ايام
الانتداب الفرنسي باللواء اسكندرون كانت
هي جزء طبعا من الاراضي السوريه كان حتى
عام 1939 ثم ضمتها تركيا الى اراضيها طبعا
حاله ذعر كبيره كان هناك حديث عن تسجيل
عدد من المصابين ليس لدينا رقم نهائي بعد
طبعا سقوط بعض الابنيه
المتهالكه او الايل للسقوط التي كانت
تضررت بسبب زلزال السادس من فبراير نشاهد
هذه الصور من شوارع اذا ريف ادلب الناس
هرعت الى سياراتها اذن وخرجت الى الشوارع
خوفا من تكرار السيناري